this you have to see
trump's lawyers are now moving on to the
next step in the deranged defense of
trump which is
the things trump might be charged with
aren't really crimes they're not really
serious these are mundane things
i know i know they started with there
were no documents and if there were
documents they were planted by the fbi
they moved on to it's trump's right to
have that stuff there and he
declassified them but then the
classification status wasn't actually
the issue
and they've moved on to all these
different arguments and the latest one
and this is beyond parody the latest one
is these are not really crimes this is
mundane stuff
trump attorney alina habba appeared
yesterday on the charlie kirk show
and you have to see this to believe it
she says look at the stuff they're
investigating trump for
things like espionage it's so mundane
now i don't know about you
but a former president being
investigated for espionage
seems pretty serious to me
but this is the new argument they're
coming up with
and
they say themselves in these papers that
they filed that this is under the
presidential records act so what they
did was to try and criminalize donald
trump as they always do they found these
three mundane statues espionage and the
two others obstruction and they're
trying to claim that there was some sort
of criminal activity but their papers
say it's under the presidential records
act so your admission
is the power that we've all been saying
he does have so you can take a picture
of top secret documents charlie and
show the world uh a label but if they're
declassified as he has the right to do
then he has the right to have them and
he would was working together with nara
as we know um and that back and forth
could have been done at a table as they
had been doing for months prior so
there's about a dozen different lies in
there the documents were not
declassified and also their
classification is not actually what's at
issue
and they were speaking with trump uh but
trump and his lawyers did not provide
back the documents the fbi was waiting
but you know it's it's lies after lie
after life
but the idea that these are just mundane
statutes like espionage i mean it's
basically jaywalking you know it's just
something police can use if they want to
mess with people or something like that
it's stunning that this is now where
they are going and by the way
uh alina habba also now places herself
at the crime scene
is she not aware of the fifth amendment
or just like you know
shutting your mouth and not saying
things that could get you pulled in to
where you might now need a lawyer here
is alina habba on fox
saying she has first-hand knowledge she
was there in trump's office
yeah nowhere what what's happened is now
they've put this picture out so that you
would assume and i am somebody who has
been and the press loves to talk about
this especially today i'm somebody that
has been in his office i've seen it this
is not the way his office looks they
give you this appearance that you walk
in and there's these top secret
documents just thrown about strong
they don't understand
something could be marked top secret
could be marked classified the
presidential records act he would have
said this is declassified it doesn't get
a new marking all the time he's left the
office all right so you get the point
and again
the classification status of the
documents for most of the crimes trump's
being investigated for is not actually
what is at issue is this the next trump
lawyer to potentially be disbarred is
this the next trump lawyer to maybe need
a lawyer remember magga making attorneys
get attorneys
um
unclear
but she doesn't have to implicate
herself as a material fact witness as so
often donald trump's lawyers end up
being it's really something else uh you
can see all these clips if you're just
listening today and curious what some of
these people look like that we're
hearing from you can find all of these
clips on our instagram just search for
david pakman show on instagram